hi I'm Nicolas p and this is the reason
podcast please subscribe to us at iTunes
and rate and review us while you're
there today I'm joined by reason editor
in chief Catherine manga award Catherine
thanks for joining today hi there Nick
and also by Matt Welch editor-at-large
of recent Matt how you doing I'm doing
I'm doing great Nick great neck I
thought you're recording from Brooklyn
that's this is going to get off to a
really good start if we go straight into
the REM dreams yeah we'll save that for
a minute to 75 I think okay so but you
are in Brooklyn right I am yes I'm in
Park Slope a beautiful park home park
slope nightmare and while this is the
reason podcast where the three senior
reason people talk about the news of the
week and let's start off by talking
about the phenomenal article about Steve
ban and the interaction with him and
Donald Trump and whatnot that was
written published in The New York Times
Magazine by a person who is also written
about reason in the past Robert Draper
math do you want to summarize the story
and what you took away as it's a key
import well the what it shows and it's
interesting because a lot of the
reporting was done before the implosion
of Ryan care of last week and you had a
lot of quotes from Steve Bannon and
president Trump himself already kind of
tacking heavily away from as if they
were starting there from the beginning
but but being very explicit in their
sense of anti libertarianism and
occasionally pro Keynesianism policies
and Trump's case he talked about he
enthusiastically agreed with Draper's
assessment that he's not interested and
not planning on doing anything serious
about entitlement reform I think he he
always saw Obamacare as you know fixing
the catastrophe but then when you asked
him throughout the campaign trail his
vision of what health care policy looks
like is actually didn't have much in
common with the people on Capitol Hill
who've been wanting to reform or replace
Obamacare
long time he's much more has a much more
kind of a government focused sense on
extending coverage to people having
those insurance programs be be tasked
with a covering a lot of different
things so in this article he's like oh
yeah for sure for sure and then he
starts talking about what we really need
to do is prime the pump and he started
using explicitly Paul Krugman like
concepts about stimulus spending in
effect and he pointed specifically to
his 1 trillion dollar infrastructure
proposal as a place that he's going to
be focusing on and we got to get that
money out there in the economy we maybe
talk a little bit later in the program
about how that is going to be one of the
next kind of coin tosses about the Trump
presidency as a whole because Democrats
are lining up to the infrastructure
thing saying good we get to spend a
trillion dollars where there's a lot of
free market people including people who
work with the recent foundation who are
hopeful crossing their fingers hopeful
maybe that this will be actually
allowing private money to get off the
sidelines and join in and build a bunch
of toll roads and things like that but
the Steve banning quotes specifically
name-checks Cato libertarian groups
Austrian economics as they live in a
fantasy land and we need to we need to
go in the sort of this real direction of
governance I think it ratifies what we
already kind of knew about Donald Trump
but it was interesting to be that
explicit at this point in the presidency
particularly after the death of Ryan
care on Friday after which President
Trump bannon and other people made a lot
of very explicit gestures towards
criticizing the house freedom caucus in
particular who attends to tend to be the
most libertarian faction of the
Republican Party as being abstinent and
unreasonable and how now they're going
to work with centrist democrats so I
think as a whole the draper piece which
is fascinating reading he's a very good
reporter I paints us a picture of an
attempt of an administration to already
within two or three months of being
alive
trying to ironically kind of bury the
the last remaining embers of the Tea
Party movement which in many ways they
had had taken over at least out in a in
the populists countryside I think it's a
very fascinating move on their part at a
time when you know Democrats aren't very
receptive to any not in their direction
from the trump presidency because he's a
deeply in unpopular and polarizing
figure Catherine do you think that
Austrian economics given the xenophobia
of this administration do they have to
start calling themselves like Alabama
economics or something is it really just
about the rebrand I think ilysm Austria
is one of the foreign countries that's
actually okay I think with this
administration and we will not Godwin
our way into why that might be true but
how about we call it a sound of music
there's sound of music school of
economics or the Von Trapp family bond
ran yeah theory only fun time to
spontaneous order yeah yeah I mean I
think this idea that you know the quote
from Bannon where he opens by trying to
call quote Tolstoy but accidentally says
it's just a esky about unhappy families
being unhappy in their own ways then
analogize is that to the two parties and
then is like n by the way [ __ ]
libertarians it's it's like a real
masterpiece of benoni in' rhetoric it's
a what you know this might be a place
where we can say we add the you know
Shaw gets turned into shave ian maybe
it's been ova in' but yeah and it's also
i think his attributing everything to
dust i have ski is kind of like one more
sign that he's the darkest human being
on the planet there's like there's no
sunshine right yeah and it's just all
like why does God let babies die
full-time wait that guy here two
questions for you Catherine related to
picking up on some of the things that
matt said first is a you know what is
the what do you think is the nut of the
anti libertarianism in a kind of Trump
Ian or state you know and we're really
talking about bannon's ideas here and
when it
you know we there's the further question
of how much is he actually influencing
or directing Trump or whether Trump is
using him and all of that kind of stuff
but what you know what is that the nut
of the antagonism and then the second
one is do they see somebody like Paul
Ryan ads libertarian because I get this
a lot when I well let's answer the first
question and then maybe we can have a
more general conversation about what is
Paul Ryan's public you know how does the
public consume him but what what do you
what is it about libertarianism that
these guys seem to hate so I think
there's an answer that's flattering to
libertarianism and one that isn't the
flattering answer is that libertarians
particularly the sort of freedom caucus
variant of libertarians are possibly the
only people who have a principled line
that they want to draw in opposition to
trump that he cares about at all I mean
of course he doesn't care if Bernie
Sanders has a deeply principled and
philosophically consistent line on why
what Trump wants to do is bad but these
guys inside his own house who are not
saying no because Trump annoys them and
they're not saying no because they're
trying to get a better deal but they are
at least sometimes saying no because
they think it is genuinely wrong to do
what Trump wants to do that's a real
barrier in a way that the kind of
wheeling and dealing of other
Republicans seems less insurmountable
the less flattering version is that it's
just with Bannon in particular like the
daylight between Bannon and Ryan on any
kind of you know if we're gonna reduce
everything to high school you know who
sat at which lunch table like it's just
subtle shades of nerd hating on each
other in a sort of small stakes
one-upmanship except for now it's large
stakes what do you think i would add so
i mean the question of who is Paul Ryan
kind of in that political psychographic
measure is pretty interesting um I think
he should be understood a lot of a UH
there's been a lot of daft commentary
since the friday shenanigans and
sometimes you will see people say oh you
know Paul Ryan he's just like a 9r and
bought in all of this Paul Ryan was the
vice presidential pick in 20
12 he was the guy who after they thomas
massie at all cashiered boehner he came
in he actually even before he became a
speaker the house he cobbled together
the deal with patty murray after the
senate was retaken by republicans to
effectively get rid of the debt ceiling
as a live political issue anymore and to
also get rid of the sequester cuts as a
live political issue so he is his job is
to do establishment t things is to make
deals is to get stuff done his job is no
longer to sit up there and cook
long-term you know 50-year reforms of
the budget process or medicare or
anything like that that's not what he
does anymore and so what's fascinating
is that trump ran is the ultimate
anti-establishment guy right and he
comes into the republican party comes in
to capitol hill and a lot of not all of
but a lot of the people who are now
firmly inside the establishment Reince
Priebus is paul ryan is a whole lot of
Tom cotton even though he's a relatively
new comer he is on these people
dutifully and their media cohorts Hugh
Hewitt for crying out loud um
immediately flip and become Trump Ian in
very strong ways he it's almost as if he
ran and he governed to prove that these
people had no principles but then what
happens he wants to get stuff done like
anyone else who's ever in charge of
anything and he looks around and he sees
what is the obstacle and so he's going
to have to grapple with this great
cognitive dissonance which is that he
ran against gormless pneus and now he's
attacking people who aren't getting
gormless and not even know what gormless
mean so now i'm generally nobody else
but he ran against the sense of that
people are unprincipled sellout who
become part of the swamp and become part
of a problem um hurry up and hurry up
become part of the swamp hurry up and
come part of the swamp lift let's RAM
together and it's truly a ramy together
unlike Obamacare was done which took a
lot longer then Ryan care did
let's ramp together something that is
almost historically unpopular not just
among the actual wonks the people who
were like Paul Ryan was ten years ago
every single free market health care
analysts from Peter Suderman on down
because he still exists at the top as we
all know thought this thing was dreadful
but it was also something like you know
seventeen percent approval ratings out
there for this plan it was just awful
the CBO scores Congressional Budget
Office scores all of it awful and so to
come out of this and and your biggest
lesson is well I know now who was
disloyal to me I is remarkable it's it's
remarkable and it's a it's going to be
this great piece of dissonance going
forward and it'll be interesting to see
to what extent Trump's support based to
which to the extent that it still exists
recognizes any of this as do anyone else
the problem with marginalizing the
freedom caucus right now is that you do
have to pass tax reform and other things
and you don't have the Democrats yet so
he's going to try to marginalize people
who are have if anything they have
popularity more on their side or more
trending on their side than Trump
doesn't i think it's just fascinating
you mentioned the swamp and i don't know
about you guys but when I think of
swamps now and I grew up in a part of
the country where there were a lot of
swamps in New Jersey many of them glowed
beautifully even during the day and dark
nights but I was think of a Cajun food I
was think of Louisiana bayous and I'm
not even sure if but now I'm hungry all
of a sudden and I realize I'm not going
anywhere with this so I'll flip it back
to Katherine at this point though what
is the I want to get back to this
question of like what is it that I had a
series of conversations last week with
people and I one of the things i was
saying asking a bunch of media type
people i was traveling in New York just
and and kind of financial sector types
what what do we need to do what do what
does reason need to do to kind of
convince the Republican Party that you
know free minds and free markets the
idea of getting rid of you know Trump
signature issues
going back towards free trade and
towards you know kind of tolerance and
pluralism these great classical liberal
ideas you know what do we need to do to
make the Republicans understand that's
the party of the future and half of them
were like those are terrible ideas I
mean is this the world we live is it has
is the world turning against what reason
has stood for and actually you know seen
a huge advances in things like the end
of tariffs essentially or the major
reduction of worldwide global tariffs a
understanding that there is a
international community that is
important it doesn't necessarily
supplant national community or local
community I mean is that is is it that
people like ban and see libertarians as
kind of are we the effete latte sippers
that the club for growth under steve
moore who is now you know an advisor at
distance to the Trump candidacy is that
who we are to people like that and if so
how do we how do we address that you
know one of the weird throw offs from
this disaster around Ryan care or
whatever it is that we're calling it is
I've seen in many different places
people saying like I hope that this
finally puts paid to the myth of Paul
Ryan as the wonk king or as the virtuous
wonk right and I think that that's a
thing that's a function that
libertarians have always served for
Republicans is to say you know while you
guys are out there glad handing in your
navy Blazers we're gonna be over here in
the corner with the spreadsheets in case
anyone's ever interested in doing actual
policy reform because you know someone's
got to do that it might as well be us
and you know I think one thing that this
has shown is that the existence of that
spreadsheet somewhere in the world does
not necessarily translate into policy
even when the guy who maybe was the
maker of that spreadsheet is in charge
of writing the legislation and and that
you know I don't actually think that
Paul Ryan as wonk King was a lie I just
think he's doing something else now and
that's what Matt was saying
about you know people being kind of
absorbed into the mainstream of this
administration versus sniping from the
outside but maybe it's also true and I
realized we've both you know we've
interviewed Paul Ryan at various points
and he's been friendly in certain ways
but one of the the main arguments or one
of the main problems always had with him
is that for all of his wonkiness he it's
you know he's like playing a game of
tetris or something or he wants to pack
the perfect grocery bag at the you know
and the checkout aisle he was never
interested in fundamentally libertarian
reform in terms of reducing the size
scope and spending of government and I
think that you know and that's before he
was speaker the house that's when he was
you know still like the jack kemp
protege in the early 2000s and it seems
to me like we should be holding him
accountable and end the republican party
i mean for you know forget Trump for a
second who's you know one thing the
Republicans had what seven years or more
to come up with a goddamn free-market
alternative to Obamacare or to have
implemented one under George Bush and
they didn't do dick about that I mean
and then they come up with a program
that sucks from everybody's perspective
it's so bad they can't even get all the
Republican votes much less a single
democratic vote and it fails and that's
really that's a big Louie you know
hanging a Luger hanging off of Paul
Ryan's face and the Republican
leadership and and you know clearly
Donald Trump as well but I mean these
they're not serious and you know Paul
Ryan was always being pilloried for
going he was going to destroy Medicare
by constantly in his budget blueprints
talking about voucher izing or giving
premium support to Medicare after the
budget window that was being talked
about in whatever document he was
publishing was actually going to start
he's you know he's a you know he's the
cabin boy rearranging deck chairs on the
Titanic he's never been a bold visionary
and I think that comes through here and
you know he's he the barber chairs
aren't even part of the conversation I
mean I guess I think I actually think
that Paul Ryan of you know ten years ago
was doing a pretty great job of walking
the line between trying to you know
repack the grocery bag or whatever but
also
keeping the end goal in mind of we at
least need to contain these programs we
at least need to stop the rate of growth
we at least need to do it that in a way
that will be long-term enough that will
be palatable I mean I actually think
that project is a noble one and one that
we should be engaged in but when we are
looking at a landscape where we have
Donald Trump saying let's prime the pump
and when asked about the border
adjustment tax he replies I am The King
of that this is not this is no longer an
environment where anyone can even hear
anything like even the most moderate of
reform plans I don't think and the total
failure of Ryan care and that's the hope
well one of the just a harp on this of
mech it your get your opinion in hopes
of finding somebody who agrees with me
more than Katherine does in in the
Draper story the Robert Draper story in
the new york times magazine which is
just really great I mean it's a
masterclass as always in reporting and
writing but it has a ton of fascinating
content in it the one thing that Trump
and Bannon and Paul Ryan could get
around was the border adjustment tax
which is essentially a tax on imports
and that that works through the
corporate system rather than the
personal tax personal income tax but you
know that's something Ryan has been in
24 years and it's just such a dumb and
complicated idea you know is there you
know what weird where do we go from here
where do libertarians go in the wake of
this failure which is pretty gigantic on
the part of Republicans and I would
argue with Chism it's fundamentally
unserious in governing because they
didn't actually come up with and sell a
plan and there was stuff out there like
Rand Paul's plan was a better
alternative than this for sure you know
there have been a thousand different
alternative proposals for a free market
system in health care you know what what
we do to to point this out to people and
say like look Obamacare is it is a
disaster it's built upon you know it's
built upon the lie that you could keep
your doctor it is you know it it forces
people to engage a nekkid economic
activity that they don't want to which
is
morally and ethically repugnant and it's
not working you know now it's time for
you know look at the sleek new
libertarian models of 2017 they're
coming to show rooms all around you and
just start talking but no the border
adjustment tax this was always going to
be the big heave number to Obamacare
reboot was number one and that totally
crashed and burned and tax reform
/border adjustment tax was always going
to be the second big awful complicated
thing that's going to happen and what
the draper article underlines and what
we've seen quotes over the weekend or
and even today including from Chuck
Schumer interestingly enough who said
that he is going to be open to doing
business with Trump on a border
adjustment tax because goodness knows
Democrats the beating heart of
democratic economic philosophy right now
has gone just a running screaming from
the bill clinton al gore era of approach
towards trade and now is resting in the
in the bosom of Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren and I'm sorry for that
image I so Jesus Christ I Sosa's
family-friendly that's true really not
so I the the question as to what
libertarians could do is pretty similar
to the question of what we could have
done and and what role we served after
the in the words of a great philosopher
Nick Gillespie our national pants
[ __ ] moments of the fall of 2008
when you had people like the wall street
journal editorial page and David Brooks
and I think even the Economist magazine
and everybody else saying you know
enough of you nihilists out there we
need to do something in order to fix the
financial crisis and it kind of doesn't
matter what that thing is let's just do
it and we were pretty lonely in the
wilderness they're saying you know when
you're in that position you're about to
do something bad and here's how it can
go bad and almost everything that we
described in terms of what could go
wrong then promptly did go wrong and
it's still wrong with us today in terms
of a sluggish
sluggishly growing recovery and and this
huge debt overhang that that is haunting
us so what we do is remind people hey
look there's a reason why you are
greeting these ideas with record
disapproval ratings of the president and
his plans there there is muscle memory
in the United States of America among
its citizens that at some point you
can't keep just doing this there are for
instance there's a the debt ceiling is
about to expire again like this week or
next week it won't no one's going to its
if it gets anywhere close Republicans
led by Paul Ryan and everybody else wave
the magic wand and it'll once again
disappear because now that they control
things they don't want impediments to
their governance but that was as I've
mentioned before one of the only things
about Republican brinksmanship back in
the day that was genuinely popular
Americans don't like the fact that we're
running such a huge high debt they
disagree strenuously about what to do
after that so our job is to remind
people of the reality of how arithmetic
works and hope and and have some kind of
sense of optimism that there will be
receptive audiences out there there's
going to be a post Trump anam Ock's and
the question is what does that look like
on the Democratic side right now I don't
have very much in the way of good
feeling about that there's been a long
trend more towards Bernie nomics and
away from from the kind of 1990s a sense
of things and then what they're going to
look like on the Republican side and the
one good thing about the way this all
went down is that I believe in that the
house freedom caucus allowed the country
and also the Republican Party to dodge a
bullet I think that even though ted Poe
was a member of the freedom caucus has
show Willie resigned even though the
wall street journal editorial page
blames the house freedom caucus solely
for this terrible result and all these
kind of things I still think that
ultimately they will gain more power in
the court of popular opinion including
among the Republican Party and when we
get to sort of thinking about post
Trumpy ISM we're going to want there to
be a place that is receptive
where I ideas so we just keep pushing
the rock uphill Nick all right and a
Katherine I want to make sure in case
any of our staff is listening or any of
our staff and we'll get to the
difficulty with possibly plural possibly
singular pronouns in a little bit but
you know that reason we also believe
that safety is job number one how many
days has it been without a
life-threatening injury at a reason
facility to do we have a count on that
one okay well it's good it's Monday so
we're we're on a hot streak so far what
are you looking forward to the
discussion about tax reform do you think
it will go any better than you know then
what we've seen with health care reform
or is it going to be I mean because the
freedom i guess this matted to your
point the freedom caucus and kind of the
modal republican mindset of just let's
cut all taxes all the time there's more
consonants there but do you have any
reason to believe Kathryn that tax
reform will be a more will be a smoother
process than health care reform for the
Republican Party you know actually think
the phrase tax reform contains a lot
more possibilities than health care
reform does which is going to be
problematic when people hear tax reform
they can hear anything from let's close
some loopholes and simplify the tax code
slightly all the way to you know let's
institute a fair tax or let's institute
a flat tax or lets you know change so
that our our budget is funded entirely
by tariffs or I mean you can you can
hear almost anything in there and I
suspect the people are right now
bridging that gap by hand waving those
differences away and we are about to
stop being able to do that I think
decreasing the corporate tax is the the
strongest point of commonality and I
think it's a good idea but I also think
that at least one I'm hearing among
libertarian wonky types is that you know
Republicans are for cutting taxes
libertarians are for cutting taxes and
correspondingly cutting spending
and that's an oversimplification but it
seems to be an increasingly important
point to make and of course we did a
cover story before the election about
what the fiscal record was of the
various candidates not in terms of
cutting taxes but in terms of actually
cutting government or setting up the
conditions to cut government in one of
our prouder moments as a magazine we
didn't even include Donald Trump in that
feature because at the time it seemed
wildly unlikely that he would be
President so we we failed to consider
the outside possibility that we will get
a president who as far as I can see has
no interest in cutting the spending of
government though he has expressed
interesting cutting the regulatory scope
and and instead is just going to cut
taxes and and that I think is in some
ways it's not a worst-case scenario but
it's not a good scenario because it gets
getting a bad name yeah and also I mean
you know part of part of our problem I
think as a country is that we've been
working with what i once called group on
government by groupon by a coupon where
we're spending you know under a large
chunk of obama's administration for
instance but we were borrowing about 33
cents on every dollar of spending and
you know it's like a discount like why
wouldn't you buy even if you don't want
the government services why wouldn't you
buy a dollar worth of [ __ ] if it only
cost you sixty-six cents out of pocket
and that goes back to reagan in a lot of
ways reagan's great innovation was to
you know get rid of any concerns about
just kind of peacetime debt in order to
get whatever you want it done and we've
you know the the budget has never really
recovered we've had mounting deficits
and hence debt since then Matt do you
think one of the things in your it
you're a New York resident Chuck Schumer
oddly is it Katherine was pointing out
that there is overlap between Democrats
and Republicans and the idea of cutting
the corporate business tax because it's
it's screwy and things like that Schumer
along with Senator Hillary Clinton who
you know whatever she's up to but they
would always vote in favor of patching
the alternative minimum tax because it
hit a lot of their constituents
who tend to be wealthier and hence
subject to that as well as corporate
taxes because you know New York City is
a town of corporations do you think that
the tax discussion about tax reform
outside of the you know there's the
within the Republican Party aspect of
things but then across the parties will
go more smoothly than you know what we
saw with the health care debacle no uh
and the reason is for me that it
actually hasn't been worked on I mean
you reference before and rightly so Nick
that Republicans had six seven years to
come up with a repeal replacement plans
for Obamacare they actually passed a lot
of bills in that process some of them
were even seen as not terrible uh you
know tom price from it was now the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
he had worked in a serious way on these
things they had done some spade work
obviously terribly inadequate and
equally as obvious they were much more
interested in demagoguing and doing
things like Ted Cruz shut down the
government and and these kind of
ridiculous politics of it but still they
did at least some work were they weren't
they haven't been doing the work on tax
reform they'll every single thing that
is that is taking a long time that
people talk about comprehensive
immigration reform tax reform you know
cutting wasteful military projects
things that you can't that somehow have
not been able to be done in Washington
for a long time I think there's a good
rule of thumb there's a reason why
they're not done even two reasons one
its really complicated and two very tied
up within that there are incentives for
not getting it done having a complicated
tax code with high taxes that allows
Congress to come in and carve out for
their own constituents a little work
arounds from those taxes allows senators
and Congress people to go and say hey
look I saved you from this aren't you
happy once you give me some campaign
contributions here it is in everyone's
best interest in order to do real tax
reform I believe you would have to go
after the mortgage interest
which is uh is ultimately using the tax
code to benefit people who are richer
than me um and so I present that right
uh very strongly but Beth you're never
going to get rid of that thing you has
been doing the hard work on laying the
groundwork for the kind of trade-offs
that a real tax reform would get so yeah
people will talk about it we got this
thirty five percent corporate tax it's
obviously one of the highest in the
world we all did nobody pays it and
nobody cuz it because it's the highest
tax rate in the world and you know let's
let's repatriate all this capital from
apple and other people by having some
kind of tax holiday we know what the
ideas are out there or I would like to
hear something about let's end the the
IRS's worldwide taxation on American
humans and corporations which is pretty
unique in the world but there's a reason
why all of these things exist so no they
haven't been doing the hard work on this
and because of that and also because of
I think that Trump will insist on a
border adjustment tax and there will be
a hardcore group probably centered
around the house freedom caucus that
will say hey I don't like tariffs I I
think I'm pessimistic from their point
of view that anything will happen but
I'm optimistic somehow that the things
that might be terrible will be avoided
you're living in a dream world man welts
you probably think the California Angels
of Los Angeles and Anaheim and now
Riverside are going to do well in the
upcoming baseball season as well I may
be optimistic but I'm not delusional
Catherine why don't we talk about the
kind of world shattering ap style guide
change that just happened and for those
of you who are thankfully not a
professional journalism ap style is a
thing the associated press because of
its impact and and reach they have a
style guide where they say use this kind
of low cution to describe this put
proper names identify people in this
format etc they just made a pretty
introduce papers mo organizations and
polluting reason follow at least a
modified version of the AP style
handbook what did the AP do recently and
why is it kind of if fascinating really
I feel like maybe the AP got tired of no
one paying attention to them so they did
a bunch of controversial things in this
update the most controversial which is
probably that they are allowing for the
first time the use of the word they as a
singular pronoun and it's a limited
change they say essentially that they
say hey well this is a collective thing
in that case but the the allowance of
the use of day as a singular or
gender-neutral pronoun when an alternate
wording is overly awkward or clumsy so
their guidance is still too right around
it if you can because of course it's
confusing is there more than one person
there or just a person who prefers that
pronoun but people are taking this as
kind of a sign of the times changing
they also added cue to LGBTQ and reasons
own Scott check for it is over at
Twitter right now losing his mind about
that in a way that's very interesting
and instructive so I urge pjs holiday is
veis losing his mind over this that was
definitely wrong in all the ways uh and
and they also changed the spelling of
kimchi so there you go ladies and
gentlemen yeah grammar yeah I with the
thing I'm a fan of DJ Khalid the super
producer and rap performer who he
doesn't do this as much now that he's
got more famous but he used to get on to
he would do elliptical training he's a
large gentleman to say to put it
diplomatically but he would he would do
live streams while doing a lip t'kul and
aerobic training and he would start to
get out of breath it was really pretty
mesmerizing but one of his self he did a
lot of kind of self-help you know Tony
Robbins style talking and his refrain
was always they don't want you to
succeed they don't want you to be better
than you are they don't want you and now
I have to go back and relook at all of
those things because was he talking
about a singular person or was he
talking about a large group of shadowy
internationalists or something like like
you think there was one person sitting
across from him holding the camera
preferred a gender-neutral pronoun and
he just hated that person I think it
might be that yeah and DJ call it is
nothing if not a master I mean he's a
master of beats of course but also of
linguistics and so this I'm happy to see
this kind of stuff I I have no problem
I've and I guess you know as like the
world's worst self proofreader I should
you know judiciously step out of this
conversation but you know this is a
language evolution isn't it I mean and
even if it did you know because the AP
is not creating this change their
certifying a change in the way that we
write and we talk and is this something
from a kind of Hayek in common law
multiple sites of evolution of social
evolution and human evolution is you
know shouldn't we be celebrating this
Katherine manga award I actually think
we should I am in favor of this change
and I think it's interesting that a
significant number of detain the changes
in this style book have to do with sex
and sexual identity I think that's the
thing we're trying to figure out how to
talk about right now and the fact that
ap is evolving to reflect that but not
jumping all over the most radical
variant just to please activists is the
right approach they also admit the use
of the word homophobia which they had
previously said no phobias or mental
illness we don't conflate those with you
know disdain or dislike or whatever so
there's a bunch of places where there
where they think they're what they're
reflecting is we're having a national
conversation about how to how to use
words to talk about peoples gender
identity and and that's that's
appropriate I also like the I mean you
know not to go all nick gillespie Pop
Tarts on people but I like the idea of
people being able to make up their own
or you know label their own identities
however they like and and to sort of
customize it to the point that they're
satisfied I do think when we get to a
place where it becomes a subjective
legal sanctioned when you use the wrong
pronoun we have gone too far and we are
marching boldly up to that
place so I am on alert for that but
anything short of that just strikes me
is delightful self-expression mad during
the great I think one of the great
definitional literally and figuratively
definitional debates of the 1990s where
were you on the great issue of whether
not Alanis Morissette understood what
irony meant because it's related it's
related though of like the stuffed
shirts being like oh she doesn't even
know what irony is how could you know
why is she selling millions of Records
and why you know that's why Dave Coulier
broke up with her I think it's important
to not impose ap style maybe Chicago
style but not AP style on 90's pop songs
I think well we would there there lies
madness in general i'm totally with a
high icky and view of language there's a
reason why american english is the best
language on the planets because we don't
get too uptight about usage we welcome
the foreigner talk we welcome new ways
of of inverting phrases and all that
kind of stuff and you can feel the but
coming in here and and and here's my
here's my but you know I'm already
dialing 911 ASAP but please continue
it's wrong they is plural right you
don't worry Genesis regular we have to
borrow it from somewhere his or her day
is better than then the one of them made
up you know I know I if something is
plural if something is singular its
singular and which is that come on Matt
I once I recall why do you like do you
work for Dean wormer at Faber College or
she also like you know loosen up man I
also appreciate oh the UH it's in the
same way that like sometimes recording
artists talk about how it's much better
to work on you know an 8-track recording
device then have use all the pro tools
and stuff I like that this awkwardness
imposed by both the English language and
the AP Stylebook requires you to do
gymnastics to write it better I
the exercise of attempting to do that
although I don't necessarily like that
as much when I'm on deadline um then
then otherwise so it's it's it's it's
simply it's it's it's it's inaccurate so
if we're gonna have professional
writings I think I think you got a
problem however they go back to the
night you have a total jihad on word
repetition and the result when you try
to write around pronouns is that you
wind up over using a person's name in a
way that sounds bizarre and
condescending I actually think writing
around it doesn't produce better writing
yeah usually doesn't you're not wrong
about that I will go with all right and
good writing good writing comes from
good thinking you can't have good
writing without good thinking that it's
really what we need to be talking about
absolutely not true thanks a lot to
transcript absolutely now Strunk is the
opposite Strunk it's all about style
isn't it it's a you know I'm talking
about there were a bunch of you know
progressive educators in the composition
space in the 70s and 80s who were like
you know when when you when you get
shitty freshman college essays or high
school you know whatever most of the
time people actually speak fairly you
know possessed and and communicative
language but they choked up when they're
writing because a lot of the times we're
asking right about stuff that they
haven't thought about and they you know
muddy muddy thinking leads to muddy
writing that's my point and it's not
it's not fixed simply by outlining your
points yeah I think Ernest Hemingway was
a pretty crappy thinker yeah about a lot
of stuff but but has stories or even
though you can never follow the plot you
get lost in the words do we have to talk
about the opening on yeah all right way
that was a that was a real real you know
kind of neutron bomb of a Hemingway joke
well you know I just hope the
microphones are still working it where
ever met and Katherine or recording from
we both I wear out yeah Katherine well
as a closing point in on an up note the
latest issue of Reason which is just a
[ __ ] cavalcade and
of interesting material and the cover
story or the cover package really is
about why border wolves don't work and
in fact there's a great piece about how
you know the border while we have yet
and the border walls are only going to
be a boon to drug and human smugglers
but I wanted to talk specifically about
the cover which is the result of a
particular printing process that you
took advantage of with Joanna andreasen
or art designer it is absolutely a
staggering experience to pick up the
latest print issue of reason and open
that cover can you talk a little bit
about what it is and what went into that
process because it really this is this
is one of those cases where you know get
the print copy of the latest issue of
reason because just opening the cover I
fine I found it genuinely moving and
affected like it's impactful which I
realize is one of those words people
either like or dislike but what's going
on in the cover so the cover package is
why the wall won't work and we took
advantage of Joanna and I went down to
visit our printer in Little Rock it was
a really cool experience just to see how
the magazine is physically produced and
while we were down there we saw some
examples of other work that they can do
including laser cutting covers so our
cover has a big hole in it just like
Trump's wall almost certainly will and
it's when you open it up you see right
through to Mexico so that is the the
general gist of the thing I actually
loved I thought there was a bunch of
good stuff in this issue about the wall
but the tidbit that I liked the most was
a sidebar to the cover package called
drug smugglers have already beaten
Trump's wall it's by Teresa Cardinal
Brown who's a former DHS staffer and she
just describes all the ways that people
are already warding walls just like the
ones that Trump wants to build more and
more of so if you need more information
about how to smuggle your marijuana VA
catapult reason magazine this month well
as I hadn't seen for that that's the
story that has the it
it's like a SUV or something that's
already like backed up on ramps over an
existing part of the wall right and to
be more to Donald Trump which I do try
to do this particular wall that has the
SUV straddling on top of it jammed up
there it's a it's a not the type of wall
that Trump favors its its vertical
bollards that people can pass things
through it is not as tall as the wall
the Trump would build it is not as
beautiful as the wall that Trump would
build I think he would want me to say
but still it's a great example of how
this like incredible you know spiked
Pike's kind of fortress looking thing
people literally just put a ramp and
drove their car up over it and this
particular car got stuck but the reason
that they were doing it is because most
of them don't so well the yeah i mean if
matt this is an old libertarian saw but
like if we can't keep drugs you know out
of prisons how are we going to keep them
across a border that is even more
difficult to police do you do you see
any shift well I guess Matt for you two
questions one is do you see any shift in
public opinion away from kind of Mexico
BIA as opposed to you know people are
worried and I think it's legitimate for
them to you know be worried about
terrorists and bad people coming into
the country and doing bad things but has
the focus of Eire shipped away from
Mexico and Mexicans because that's that
was what Trump and Katherine and your
excellent note were you opening essay in
the in the issue area among other things
you said people write on what Robert
Frost was talking about in mending wall
his famous poem but Matt are we less
worried about Mexicans now or not and so
how important to the people that you
hang out like your neighbors and whatnot
in Brooklyn a very liberal Enclave a
super liberal enclave how important is
it to be right with them on immigration
by which I simply mean that you're not
seen as xenophobic is that if you don't
have that the conversation is over um so
I I think it's always important in
American politics to be aware of the
pendulum effect so at any given time
when it really looks like we are forever
to be in X that's a pretty good sign to
start betting long on Y and and you and
I talked about this at a great length in
a declaration of independence neck and I
think that's right the the go to
possible historical analogy for our
current expression and kind of
ratification of what has been a minority
strain in mostly Republican politics of
a simple-minded kind of either mexa
phobia or simple-minded we have an easy
solution to a complicated immigration
problem is what happened with Pete
Wilson in California in 1993 1994 when a
guy who was already Governor of
California Republican a moderate from
San Diego was 20 points underwater and
he was looking around and noticing that
in the post-cold war kind of recession
ravaged early 90s California that there
was a rise in kind of blaming the
Mexicans on stuff so he went all in on
that and was successful as was
Proposition 187 in 1994 and so a lot of
people go back and read the coverage of
you know the LA Times the New York Times
elsewhere it's like wow that's you know
it's it's going to be all anti
immigration from here on out well
actually it's going to be that's the
last we'll ever see of Republicans not
named Arnold Schwarzenegger Republicans
who have themselves been possibly
illegal immigrants from here on out in
California that effectively croaked the
Republican Party there's people who
dispute that but I think that's a that
is broadly more true than not true and i
think you know Donald Trump's sense
solutions for immigration have never
really been a majoritarian among the
American population and something that
you've written about a lot Nick most
Americans kind of favor the direction of
where comprehensive immigration reform
was going as flawed as that set of
packages definitely has been over the
years people want a path toward some
kind of legal normalization whether that
looks like citizenship or something else
and so after this expression when we're
going to go through at least
this wall building which we have been
doing in for the last 20 years as this
great package does point out but after
we go through the eminent domain fights
after we see the end result of all of
this which is going to be more people
buying in the desert um uh people
realizing that the largest majority the
greatest number of people who are who
become illegal in this country and this
is huge numbers already are people who
came here legally not because they cross
the swam across the border it's because
they came here on a student visa or some
other type of visa and just overstayed
so after all that and are increasingly
from the two biggest groups now our
Chinese and Indians both for Norma legal
and unauthorized immigration so Mexicans
are third who don't come over the
southern border after all of this plus
the unpopularity of Donald Trump I
unless unless he waited something
strange happens and things do happen
strangely in American politics let's be
clear about that you know if the economy
suddenly goes great for the next five
years these predictions might be wrong I
I'm doubtful about all of that so the
pendulum will swing backwards and I
think we might see particularly given
that Millennials hold up as their
primary political virtue being opposed
to bigotry I think we might see the this
this is will be the beginning of the end
but we don't know where that pendulum is
it still may be doing a back swing we
still maybe have a ways to go on this
and we certainly have a lot of
individual lives that will be swept up
into whatever is going to happen next so
eventually it'll go back but and in
swing in the other direction but I don't
know where we are right there I you know
how you guys I run into this argument a
lot like you know show me one place
where Donald Trump has said he's against
immigration he's only against illegal
immigration or I'm not against
immigration I'm just against illegal
immigration I'm looking forward to the
moment where that becomes i'm not
against all illegal immigration i'm just
against mexican illegal immigration and
this was dia that a point about that at
that we always stress but it's worth
stressing every time we talk about it is
that he wants to cut down
his closest advisors led by Steve Bannon
wants to cut down pretty drastically the
amount of legal eighty percent fifty
percent from governor's cotton and
Purdue Republican senators introduced
legislation almost a month ago now to
say legal immigration which has been
around a million people a year they hate
h-1b visas which is a program for
workers in short supply etc but yeah so
I mean like the I mean nobody I don't
know anybody who is actually in favor of
immigration who is also against illegal
immigration the two are intertwined
because Matt as you were saying a lot of
you know a lot of illegal immigrants
certainly they come to the country and
it said something like two thirds now it
used to be forty percent came in legally
on a travel visa student visa whatever
and then overstay now it's up to
two-thirds so rendering the whole wall
idea kind of ridiculous but it did give
rise and like I think absolutely
Katherine just one of the greatest
[ __ ] covers in in recent history so
the untold suffering and misery of
millions of people and I and I'm making
a joke here you know at least it gave
rise to a really great cover but I think
Matt one of the things that is really
always worth talking about and pointing
out is the misery that gets inflicted by
these dumb stupid rules you know because
I like you I'm generally optimistic
about things and you know we are
witnessing in a way that I never thought
we would you know the end of the war on
drugs where you know we're taking baby
steps towards that and whatnot but
between now and the end of end of pot
legalization there will literally be
millions of people's whose lives are
absolutely ruined waiting for the
obvious to happen and you know when we
should never lose sight of you know the
the human toll of all of this kind of
stuff I mean as your friend sorry Nick
just shout out one of your greater
headlines is you know who will be the
last one to die for the drug war daddy
is uh is something we should never lose
sight of actually it was what did you do
during the drug war daddy whatever don't
correct me yeah but uh
Catherine where can people subscribe to
and by reason magazine because again and
and the reason I'm harping on the cover
is we've you know we've got three
editors of the magazine here we've each
had like kind of spectacular covers this
is just such a masterpiece and I think I
mentioned to you in a previous
conversation I I'm you know and it's
partly because obviously I have you know
all sorts of had medical problems but
when I opened that cover up I was
staggered by it I actually literally sat
down because I was like it took my
breath away it is so powerful I showed
it to my sons and they were knocked out
by it and kind of almost laughing
because it's it's just so great I really
hope that people seek out the physical
object on this and what's the best way
for them to do that they can subscriber
reason.com they can go to their friendly
neighborhood newsstand if such a thing
still exists anywhere near them and and
pick up a copy of course i will say Nick
that on my Twitter feed as people were
getting their issues in the mail lots of
people saying this cover is awesome I
love it not quite as good not quite as
good as the one with the picture of my
house on it that was the best cover ever
so or at every single ID forget why
couldn't it be about something other
than a legal immigration which I'm
against we and I will end this reason
talk show podcast with a true story from
Queens New York where a couple of reason
TV guys and myself we were we had taped
a couple things and we were getting into
an uber and a guy drove by and he was
like hey hey reason right reason and he
literally held up the issue it I put it
I think in the both the reason Twitter
feed as well as my own but a guy named
tan ver Troy who is he grew up in Queens
and he was he was showing the issue and
like opening the cover and it was you
know it's it's those kinds of moments
that are really you know are really it's
special to be working with you guys and
to be part of an organization like
reason where you know that people are
you know where we're channeling a lot of
energy and a lot of ideas and pushing it
back to people in ways that
an influence on them so thank you for
all that will end it here this is the
reason podcast we've been talking with
Matt Welch editor-at-large of reason
Matt thanks for participating good times
and we've been talking with a reason
editor-in-chief Reason magazine editor
in chief Catherine manga ward Thank You
Catherine thank you nick and i am nick
gillespie this has been the reason
podcast please subscribe to us at iTunes
and rate and review us while you're
there thanks for listening